I'm here to tell you how change is
happening at a local level in Pakistan
because women are finding their place in
the political process I want to take you
all on a journey to the place I was
raised not West Pakistan called dheere
dheere was founded in the 17th century
it was a princely state until its merger
with Pakistan in 1969 our Prensa Nawab
Shah Jahan reserved the right to wear
white the color of honor but only for
himself he didn't believe in educating
his people and at the time of my birth
in 1979 only five percent of boys in 1%
of girls received any schooling at all I
was one among that 1% growing up I was
very close to my father he is a pharmacy
doctor in he sent me to school every day
I will go to his clinic when my lessons
finished he's a wonderful man in a
well-respected community leader he was
leading a welfare organization and I
would go with him to the social and
political gatherings to listen and talk
to the local men about our social and
economic problems however when I was 16
my father asked me to stop coming with
him to the public gatherings now I was a
young woman and my place was in the home
I was very upset but most of my family
members they were happy with this
decision it was very difficult for me to
sit back in the home and not be in world
it took two years that finally my family
agreed that my father could reconnect me
with women and girls
so they could share their problems and
together we could resolve them so with
his blessings I started to reconnect
with women in girls so we could resolve
their problems together when women show
up they brings the realities and views
with them and yet I have found all too
often women and discrimate their own
strengths their potential and their
self-respect
however while connecting with these
women in girls it became very clear to
me that if there was to be any hope to
create a better life for these women and
girls in their families we must stand up
for our own rights and not wait for
someone else to come and help us so I
took a huge leap of faith and founded my
own organization in 94 to create our
very own platform for women empowerment
I engaged many women and girls to work
with me
it was hard many of the women working
with me had to leave once they got
married because their husbands wouldn't
let them work when colleague of mine was
given away by her family to make amends
for a crime her brother had committed I
couldn't help her and I felt so helpless
at that time but it made me more
determined to continue my struggle
I saw many practices like these where
these women suffered silently bearing
this brutality but when I see a woman
struggling to change her situation
instead of giving up it motivates me so
I ran for a public office as an
independent candidate in lower deed and
the local elections in two
thousand one despite all the challenges
and hurdles I faced throughout in this
process I won and I served in the public
office for six years but unfortunately
we women elected women we were not
allowed to sit in the council together
with all the members and to take part in
the proceedings we had to sit in a
separate ladies only room not even aware
what was happening in the council men
told me that you women elected women
members should by swing machines for
women when I knew what they needed the
most was access to clean drinking water
so I did everything I could do to
prioritize the real challenges these
women faced I set up five hand pumps in
the two dried-up wells in my locality
well we got them working again before
long we made water accessible for over
5,000 families we proved that anything
the man could do so could we women
I built alliances with other elected
women members in last year we women were
allowed to sit together with all the
members in the council
and to take part in the legislation in
planning and budgeting in all the
decisions I saw there is strength in
numbers you know yourselves lack of
representation means no one is fighting
for you Pakistan is were eight thousands
miles away from where I am here with you
today but I hope what I am about to tell
you will resonate with you though we
have this big distance in miles in in
our cultures when women sure they bring
the realities and hopes of haba
population with them in 2007 we saw the
rise of the Taliban in Swat deed in
nearby districts it was horrifying
the Taliban killed innocent people
almost everyday people collected the
dead bodies of their loved ones from the
streets most of the social and political
leaders struggling and working for the
betterment of their communities were
threatened and targeted even I had to
leave leaving my children behind with my
in-laws I closed my office indeed and
relocated to Peshawar the capital of my
province I was in trauma kept thinking
what to do next and most of the family
members and friends they were suggesting
shots stopped working the threat is very
serious but I persisted
in 2009 we experienced a historic influx
of internally displaced persons from
swat lead in other nearby districts I
started visiting the camp's almost every
day until the internally displaced
person started to go back to their place
of origin I established for model child
health care units especially to take
care of world 10,000 women and children
nearby the camps but you know during all
these my wizards I observed that there
was very less attention towards women
needs and I was looking for it what is
the reason behind it and I found it was
because of the under-representation of
women in both social and political
platforms in our society as a whole and
that was the time when I realized that I
need to narrow down my focus on building
and strengthening women's political
leadership to increase your political
representation so they would have their
own voice in their future so we started
training around 300 potential women in
youth for the upcoming local elections
in 2015 and you know what 50% of them
won
and they are now sitting in the
council's taking part actively in the
legislation planning and budgeting most
of them are now investing their funds on
women's health education skill
development and safe drinking water
these all elected women now they share
discuss and resolve their problems
together let me tell you about two or
women I have been working with Saira
shams you can see this young lady
age 26 she ran for a public office in
2015 in lower the and she won she
completed two of the community
infrastructure schemes
you know women community infrastructure
schemes some people think this is man's
job but no this is woman's job too we
can do it and she also fixed two of the
roads leading towards girls schools
knowing that without access to these
schools they're useless to the girls of
their and another young woman is Ozma
Ghul she is a very active member of the
young leaders forum who established she
was unable to run for the public office
so she has become a first female
journalist of our region she speaks in
rights for women and girls issues in
their rights Saira and Ozma they are the
living examples of the importance of
inclusion and representation let me tell
you this too in the 2013 general
elections in Pakistan in the local
elections in the 2015 there were less
than 100 women voters indeed but you
know what I'm proud to tell you that
this year during the general elections
there were 93 thousand women voters in
dear
so our struggle is far from world but
this shift is historic and a sign that
women are standing up showing up and
making it absolutely clear that we all
must invest in building women's
leadership in Pakistan and here in the
United States and everywhere in the
world
this means women in politics women in
business and women in positions are
power making important decisions
it took me 23 years to get here but I
don't want any girl or any woman to take
23 years of her life to make herself
heard I have had some dark days but I
have spent every waking moment of my
life working for the right of every
woman to live her full potential
imagine with me
a world where thousands of us stand up
and they support other young women
together creating opportunities in
choices that benefit all and that my
friends can change the world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]